When we have independence,
does anything interesting
happen to expectations?
We know that, in general, the
expected value of a function
of random variables is not the
same as applying the function
to the expected values.
And we also know that there are
some exceptions where we
do get equality.
This is the case where we are
dealing with linear functions
of one or more random
variables.
Note that this last property
is always true and does not
require any independence
assumptions.
When we have independence,
there is one additional
property that turns
out to be true.
The expected value of the
product of two independent
random variables is
the product of
their expected values.
Let us verify this relation.
We are dealing here with the
expected value of a function
of random variables, where the
function is defined to be the
product function.
So to calculate this expected
value, you can use the
expected value rule.
And we are going to get the sum
over all x, the sum over
all y, of g of xy, but in this
case, g of xy is x times y.
And then we weigh all those
values according to the
probabilities as given
by the joint PMF.
Now, using independence, this
sum can be changed into the
following form--
the joint PMF is the product
of the marginal PMFs.
And now when we look at the
inner sum over all values of
y, we can take outside the
summation those terms that do
not depend on y, and so this
term and that term.
And this is going to yield a
summation over x of x times
the marginal PMF of X, and then
the summation over all y
of y times the marginal PMF of
Y. But now we recognize that
here we have just the expected
value of Y. And then we will
be left with another expression,
which is the
expected value of X. And this
completes the argument.
Now, consider a function of X
and another function of Y. X
and Y are independent.
Intuitively, the value of X
does not give you any new
information about Y, so the
value of g of X does not to
give you any new information
about h of Y. So on the basis
of this intuitive argument, the
functions g of X and h of
Y are also independent
of each other.
Therefore, we can apply the
fact that we have already
proved, but with g of X in the
place of X and h of Y in the
place of Y. And this gives us
this more general fact that
the expected value of the
product of two functions of
independent random variables is
equal to the product of the
expectations of these
functions.
We could also prove this
property directly without
relying on the intuitive
argument.
We could just follow the same
steps as in this derivation.
Wherever there is an X, we
would write g of X, and
wherever there is a Y, we would
write h of Y. And the
same algebra would go through,
and we would end up with the
expected value of g of X times
the expected value of h of Y.